[Musique]
alors que se tient une réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'otan et que les relations libano
israélienne sont en train d'être abordée
au conseil de sécurité le liban a
longtemps été un front clé des conflits
de la guerre froide et on peut dire
qu'il est toujours beyrouth à les
accueillir le communiste connu pour
avoir pénétré avec le plus de succès les
services secret britannique kim philby
nouveau livre concernant la période de
sa vie à beyrouth ne se contente pas
d'explorer la vie et les amours du
légendaire agent double et passe aussi
en revue le rôle qu'ont joué les
questions de classe dans les défaites
britannique de la guerre froide son
auteur l'ancien rédacteur en chef
adjoint deux îles dépendantes on sunday
en angleterre james hanning ce jour un
mois james je pensais que tout le monde
connaissait déjà kim philby le plus
fameux des espions britanniques après
james bond c'est bien je pensais qu'on
connaissait tous l'histoire de fil dit
qu'elle avait été exploitée à fond mais
en réalité je me suis penché dessus
parce que j'avais obtenu quelques
informations intéressantes de la part de
mon ancien collègue brian si wall
concernant les circonstances dans
lesquelles philby a quitté beyrouth donc
j'ai commencé à me pencher dessus et je
me disais je ne savais pas ça je ne
savais pas ça concernant sa femme
américaine il y avait beaucoup de choses
et j'ai pensé c'est un de ces
personnages qui font partie de la
conscience collective mais je me suis
rendu compte que j'en avais beaucoup
oublié à son sujet
il ya beaucoup de nouveaux éléments
particulièrement parce qu'avec brian
simo elle lance un critique d'art d'un
journal londonien qu'il connaissait
anthony blunt ce que vous aviez toute la
galerie de tableaux de la rave mais je
veux dire nous avons eu androula honni
pour son livre sur philby qu'il a écrit
récemment et vous lui fait écho quand
vous insistez sur le fait qu'il y a une
vraie dimension de classe à la faire il
était protégé en tant qu agent
soviétique ou plus aux échelons des
services secrets britanniques à cause de
sa classe sociale
les classes
bien sûr il ne savait pas qu'il était un
agent des russes faute mais tout le
monde se disait que c'était un type bien
mais son père était connu il était passé
par cambridge et connaissez beaucoup de
gens à cambridge et c'est donc on
considérait que c'était un type bien il
est 13 ème à tripoli très gentil au très
charismatique très charismatique je
pense oui les femmes l'adorait quelqu'un
dit qu'il avait une sorte d'aura
sexuelle quand il entrait dans une pièce
rappelez-nous pourquoi elle s'est
tournée vers le communisme je pense que
beaucoup de gens s'ils savent qu'ils
aient philby s'ils savent que c'est un
traître auront vu des livres au vitriol
contre les gens qui sont morts parce
qu'ils espionnaient pour les soviétiques
je crois que je n'ai jamais lu ça dans
un livre anglais au sujet de philby ils
avaient une conscience sociale ses
parents ses amis de sa classe sociale
l'excès créé il l'avait corrompu il
avait vu comment la gauche
social-démocrate avait vacillé son
incapacité à faire face au fascisme la
modération des principes de sa jeunesse
comme le parti travailliste s'étaient
vendus à gauche de ram si mcdonald's je
ne sais pas certains pourraient dire la
gauche de kir starmer l'austérité ce
fascisme
le royaume uni la majeure partie de
l'europe a traversé une période très
dure à la fin des années 20 et au début
des années 30
ils étaient horrifiés par le fait que le
parti travailliste qui était alors
considéré comme le moyen
conventionnelles pour s'opposer au
capitalisme se soit vendu
[Musique]
qu'il entre dans un gouvernement d'unité
nationale comme on appelait cela
ils pensaient que la gauche s'étaient
vendus et très rapidement il est allé
ensuite en autriche puis en espagne
il était révolté il se disait la
démocratie la démocratie sociale ne fait
pas le travail et il a vu l'avènement
d'hitler en allemagne
est bien sûr celui de mussolini en
italie et celui de franco en espagne
donc il regardait l'union soviétique
comme un bastion anti fasciste
tout le bloc plus tard il est allé à
cuba après avoir fait défection
tout à fait je pense que c'était un
idéaliste
c'est un fanatique d'un point de vue
idéologique
vous voyez il considérait que la
politique démocratique ne ferait rien
pour la classe ouvrière
idéologique que les gens qui en théorie
est et ses meilleurs amis même s'ils les
tromper et qui était impliqué dans le
coup contre moussadek en iran qui était
impliqué dans toutes sortes d'activités
de renseignement pour détruire des
parties du sud
[Musique]
oui il était il était de l'autre côté je
pense que l'autre chose qu'il ne faut
pas oublier à son sujet et qu'il avait
des capacités extraordinaires pour la
tromperie c'était un menteur tout à fait
brillant
mais après il me semble qu'il n'y a pas
de raison pour que quelqu'un qui a ce
talent tu si on estime que c'est un
talent n'est pas d'aspirations supérieur
pour la société
vous pouvez très bien être un idéaliste
est un menteur
vous êtes journaliste
on peut dire que vous êtes l'un des
meilleurs experts britanniques des excès
des oligarques sur le journalisme dans
ce pays il est tout à fait déprimant
pour tout journaliste de lire au sujet
de la capture du journalisme par les
renseignements américains et
britanniques dans les années 50 et 60
alors racontez nous comment il se
retrouve à travailler pour 10 observeur
et des économistes à beyrouth
sur la capture c'est votre terme je ne
crois pas que j'utiliserai un terme
pareil je veux dire la femme qu'il
épouse en dernier son ancien mari ça
brewer qui travaillaient pour des
journaux new-yorkais vous n'êtes pas
tendre avec lui
samro heures avait travaillé pendant la
guerre pour le prédécesseur de la cia et
avait été journaliste
quand il a quitté son journal pour
rejoindre le new york times
le new york times lui a dit vous devez
couper tous vos liens avec les services
de sécurité
a dit oui bien sûr je vais faire ça mais
je ne pense pas que quiconque ait cru
qu'il l'ait fait mais les journalistes
vous le diront partout dans le monde tue
les gens du renseignement parle tout
journaliste et vice et versa il y a une
relation assez symbiotique et je ne
parlerai pas de capture
aux rédacteurs en chef de die observeur
david astor était heureux de voir tous
ces journalistes plutôt que de dire la
vérité aux puissants pour dire les
choses ainsi être des sténographes
je ne suis pas un expert du dossier
david as tort mais je pense qu'il était
plutôt assez naïf
il y avait vraiment le sentiment sincère
qu'on avait causé du tort à philby il
avait été maltraité il avait été accusée
d'espionner pour les russes et en fin de
compte le gouvernement britannique en
1955 l'avait blanchi ses amis disait on
vous avait dit qu'il n'espérait pas pour
les russes il faut prendre soin de lui
c'est un type bien il est direct il faut
qu'on lui trouve un travail donc ils lui
ont comme vous l'avez dit trouver un
travail au sein des serveurs un des
économistes ils l'ont envoyée à beyrouth
comme vous avez travaillé au evening
standaard il me faut vous poser cette
question parce que christopher steele
agent du mi6 discréditer qui a été
interviewé en fanfare récemment ce que
boris johnson avait fait entrer le fils
du patron du evening standaard enfin à
vrai dire c'est lui désormais le patron
du mjic standaard le russe evgueni
lebedev à la house of lords comme si
boris johnson venons de la même classe
était un espion russe je veux dire il y
avait des espions russes autour de vous
evening standaard aucun ma connaissance
on m'a dit que jack le caricaturiste si
vous vous en souvenez on disait que jack
était sur une liste d'agents
mais c'est un domaine très obscur et
comme je le disais beaucoup de
journalistes parlent aux gens du
renseignement ils échangent des
informations ils s'entraident
s'il y a de l'argent en jeu j'estime que
c'est une ligne rouge de franchi
je ne sais pas mais concernant voorhees
oui je pense que quelqu'un pourrait
inventer tout are you avec le père de
boris quand on a dit qu'il était du mi6
et boris qui était allé à eaton etc on
peut en tirer quelque chose
cela sonne comme une conversation au bar
saint georges à beyrouth décrivez cet
endroit c'est malheureusement l'objet
d'informations en ce moment à cause de
ce qu'il se passe au liban
mais ce qu'il se passe au liban affecte
le moyen-orient est donc le monde entier
le saint-georges c'était je veux dire
beyrouth ont été en quelque sorte le
nouveau caire beaucoup de gens quitter
le caire des gens du renseignement des
journalistes des hommes d'affaires
il était nerveux à cause de nasser et
pensaient que le liban serait un endroit
plus sûr pour les enfants
donc ça semblait être un lieu très
joyeux du moins si vous aviez un peu
d'argent
le gouvernement était un proxy des états
unis oui ça l'était et le saint georges
le bar de l'hôtel saint georges était
l'endroit où les diplomates les espions
les journalistes se retrouvait le soir
voire de temps à autre le matin ils
pouvaient y passer la journée
c'était l'endroit où il fallait se
trouver si vous vouliez savoir ce qui se
passait
vous étiez sûr d'y trouver quelques
membres importants du gouvernement où
quelques espions importants ou quelqu'un
d'autre
c'était l'endroit où il fallait se
trouver
c'était mieux que des communiqués de
presse mais la quantité d'alcool
constant dans ce livre le 10 heures
racontez nous ce qu'est le club de 10
heures du matin
tu compris alors le le club de 10 heures
du matin
les deux présidents de ce club était
sympa brewer
dont la femme finira par épouser philby
et un de ses amis qui étaient de la cia
il arrivait à 10 heures prenez leur
courrier et un journal sous le bras
aller s'asseoir et au bar il bavardait
et buvez leur premier martini à 10
heures ils discutaient de ce dont le new
york times traiterait le lendemain mais
sam brewer était devenu un peu trop
dépendant de sa de ces sources
officielles
ce qui est d'ailleurs triste parce que
plus tard oui je pense qu'on connaît
tous des journalistes qui deviennent
trop dépendant de sources de
renseignements
ici gros scandale avec l'intégrité
initiative of institute for statkraft
les hauts faits une liste de
journalistes à favoriser pour les fuites
ce document affûté je n'étais pas dans
la liste je ne sais pas si vous y étiez
mais on ne me dit rien
on me donne aucune information
mais la cia est incroyablement embêté
par tout ça est à juste titre il donne
une histoire il donne des informations
alors pourquoi les américains n'ont ils
pas je veux dire vous avancez une
théorie selon laquelle ils voulaient le
tuer dès qu'ils ont découvert que
c'était un espion et ensuite vous entrez
dans une longue explication de
différentes théories
notamment une selon laquelle les
services de renseignements ici sont
allés en un sens le sauver et le faire
partir pour moscou parce qu'il ne
voulait pas de procès public qui
embarrasserait des services de
renseignement en face au reste du monde
je ne pense pas qu'il soit allé à
beyrouth pour l'encourager à aller à
moscou
je pense qu'il croyait toujours
même quand il était quasiment sûr qu
effectivement philby avait espionné pour
les russes
il croyait toujours qu'il pouvait
leur tournée leur tournée l'un des
secrets l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique et
notamment si je peux dire les russes
mais les britanniques croyait toujours
que ce bon vieux kim malgré tout resté
l'un des nôtres
que s'il le mettait face à ce qu'il
considère être une folie de jeunesse
sont anti fascisme et c'est que s'il lui
disait écoute on peut passer un accord
revient chez nous dit nous qui d'autres
étaient impliqués on pourra tout oublier
et qu'une fois qu'ils auraient cette
confession il avait une sorte de
confession je le sais ça n'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour certaines personnes
mais il avait une sorte de confession de
sa part
avec quelques fausses informations là
dedans
avec certainement quelques fausses
informations ce qu'il faisait exactement
n'est pas clair mais il était au moins
en train d'essayer de gagner du temps
mais il me semble que les britanniques
pensaient qu'une fois qu'ils auraient
cette confession
considérerait que kim est de retour il
va nous dire il peut rester à beyrouth
il va nous dire ce qui s'est passé
et c'est pour cela que nicolas l'yonne
était à l'aise à l'idée d'aller à
londres et ensuite je crois en afrique
où était sa mission suivante
cela semble surprenant que dick white du
aim high five dans le bâtiment à côté de
ce studio est pensé après des décennies
de fuite de temps d'information et de
secret vers le kgb qu'il pourrait leur
tournée eh bien il me semble qu'il ne
voulait pas partir
je pense que l'angleterre lui manquait
quand il est arrivé à moscou
c'est une zone très trouble
je ne peux vous assurer qu'il était fou
amoureux d'eleanor
car personne ne sait ce qui se passait
dans la tête de file be mais s'il me
semble qu'il l'aimé vraiment beaucoup il
se plaisait à beyrouth buvais énormément
mais
c'est sa troisième femme qui l'a trompé
à moscou après avoir fait défection
c'est exact
mais je pense qu'en fin de compte il
n'avait pas vraiment envie d'aller à
moscou
mais c'est ce qu'il a fait pour les
raisons que je développe dans le livre
[Musique]
il ya un problème là ils ne sortent
aucun papier ni colas elliott son
meilleur ami au sein des services de
renseignement a travaillé sur ses
mémoires qu'il voulait pour 2021 ils ne
peuvent pas les publier pourquoi ça
bien un expert de l'espionnage m'a dit
que le mi6 ne révélaient jamais quoi que
ce soit tout simplement parce que c'est
mauvais pour les affaires cela crée un
un mauvais précédent
si vous révéler quoi que ce soit
ça peut miner la confiance et du le four
de manière sélective
des choses arrivent jusqu'aux
journalistes oui il y a des choses comme
ça mais je suis d'accord je ne sais pas
pourquoi il ne sort pas spécifiquement
la version de nicolas elliott de la même
manière je ne suis pas sûr que nikolai y
connaissait toute l'histoire
comme je le dis dans le livre je pense
qu anthony blunt un rôle majeur dont les
gens n'étaient pas au courant
je veux y venir car je n'étais pas du
tout au cours de ceux là c'est l'un des
plus fameux critique d'art britannique
critique des tableaux de la reine amis
de la reine pendant longtemps
lié à la mère de la reine oui oui
famille éloignée il ya tellement de
choses dont ce livre john le carré
apparaît de manière terrible avec sa
volonté de tuer philby
mais il parlait mois de belote pourquoi
était-il à beyrouth à peu près au même
moment alors que normalement il devrait
être à londres à l'institut pour tous
exactement
il me semble même si je dois avouer et
qu'il s'agit de spéculations
que j'ai prouvé que blunt était à
beyrouth trois ou quatre semaines avant
que philby ne se trouve face à elliott
elle est je pense que blunt avait
compris que philby allait devoir être
confrontés
bleus avaient perdu la foi dans le
communisme
j'ai parlé à youri modine à moscou il ya
environ 18 ans et il m'a dit que blunt
avait totalement perdu la foi dans le
communisme
et il n'a jamais été engagée
c'était un marxiste dans un sens
esthétique mais il s'est joint à
l'aventuré à cause de son ami guy bergès
et la foi de bluff dans l'union
soviétique avait disparu
je pense que quand blunt a entendu que
philby allait être confronté qu'il a
senti d'abord par fidélité envers philby
ensuite pour sauver sa tête ce qu'ils
avaient peur de ce que philby pour elle
raconté qu'il devait aller lui-même à
beyrouth pour le dira philby
les gens se demandent pourquoi
ne s'est tout simplement pas adressé à
l'ambassade soviétique à londres
contact à londres
parce que je pense que blanc tu voulais
donner à philby le choix ils avaient
peur que si les russes étaient impliqués
le futur de philby pourrait échapper à
ce dernier que les russes disent ok vous
venez avec nous
il voulait que philby et l'opportunité
d'être avertis et de prendre une
décision par lui-même
plutôt que tout soit décidé par les
russes
vous rigolez enfin philby rigole quand
il est confronté face au fait qu'il est
un espion et répond évidemment que je
suis en espion en fait selon m n on a
beaucoup couvert le yémen la pire crise
humanitaire au monde quand la révolution
marxiste y éclatent en 1962 dans le sud
du yémen c'est évident pour ses amis
dit il me semble que vers la fin de sa
vie il songer à la guerre civile
espagnole à l'austérité aux pauvres et
aux inégalités
et les gens disaient qu'est l'homme
surveillants
c'est exact et l'un de ses anciens
correspondants un employé du télégraphe
quelques jours avant que philby ne
disparaisse de beyrouth dit c'est
vraiment un type bien
il est vraiment mue par des
considérations humanitaires
je pense que c'est exact il n'est pas
bien considérés en angleterre pour des
raisons évidentes il a trahi beaucoup de
gens il a trompé du p peu importe
mais je pense qu'il mérite au moins un
peu qu'on comprenne ses motivations
d'où cela vient
d'accord donc à l'heure actuelle nous
avons en leader travailliste de droite
nous avons l'austérité des effets de la
crise de 2008 la hausse des inégalités
sous les gouvernements travaillistes et
conservateurs
rires on a des guerres des guerre
désastreuse notamment l'afghanistan
récemment alors qu est-ce que selon vous
philby aurait pensé de la situation
actuelle ah
je me le demande
il ya toujours beaucoup de partisans de
corps bin dans la classe moyenne
il ya toujours des gens qui pensent
qu'on a besoin de quelque chose de plus
extrême
est ce que philby
non je ne sais pas il garderait
peut-être le secret c'est toute la
question
c'est arnold deutsch qui l'a recruté
dans les années 30 qui lui a dit vous
pourriez faire beaucoup plus si vous
agissez de manière clandestine
je pense qu'il n'y a pas à débattre de
ça je veux dire il a fait beaucoup de
dégâts à l'ouest donc de ce point de vue
deutsch avait raison est-ce que philby
feu la même chose de nos jours je ne
sais pas
cela lui a énormément coûté en matière
d'amitié personnelle on peut même dire
que c'est ce qu'ils cherchaient et toute
cette boisson
ce n'était pas un homme heureux personne
ne peut prétendre qu'il était heureux il
n'était peut-être inspiré par deco
supérieur mais personne ne peut dire
qu'il était heureux
alors qu'ici dans les années 50 et 60 en
lisant les journaux tout le monde
pouvait voir à quel point l'union
soviétique était diabolique dans sa
perspective voyant l'impérialisme
britannique mourir je veux dire vers la
fin quand il est à beyrouth avec les
échos de nasser et de la crise de suez
toujours très important
je pense je pense que blunt et lui
d'après ce que j'ai lu de ce que blanc
ne pouvait penser à ce sujet sentait
philby en 1933 en 1934 avait dit la
guerre arrive la guerre avec hitler
arrive je pense qu'il sentait qu'il
pouvait voir l'avenir et je dis ça sans
facéties je pense qu'il sentait que
l'histoire était de son côté et cela
fait partie d'une analyse globale du
colonialisme
et je pense qu'il se sentait tout à fait
justifiée par cela et puis avec tout ce
qui se passait avec eden et c'était
vraiment n'importe quoi
pourquoi n'at-il pas été impressionné
par washington c'était le responsable du
mi6 le plus important à washington de la
même manière qu'il avait précédemment
dirigé le département anti russie anti
union soviétique alors même qu'il était
un espion soviétique ici à londres sinon
je pense qu'il était à 6 nov je suis
tombé sur quelques notes que personne
n'avait jamais vu auparavant des notes
de patrick s'il est écrit une biographie
de philby
quelqu'un de très proche de file be
avait parlé à s'il est tous les dix ans
à quel point il était malheureux à
washington il faisait mine de s'y plaire
mais il n'aimait vraiment pas à cet
endroit
je pense qu'il avait l'impression que
les américains étaient un peu vulgaire
j'ai connu pas très difficile et vous
dit qu'il était dans les renseignements
vraiment je ne dis pas ça
ou alors c'était son père je ne pense
pas que son père en était
parce que patrick s'il était connu pour
sa biographie du père d'assad
pensez vous qu'il y a des restes de tout
cela dans les couloirs de l'ong lit en
virginie à la cia
cette idée qu'on ne peut pas vraiment
tout à fait faire confiance aux
britanniques que dans leur services de
renseignement la classe sociale a
toujours son importance
je ne sais pas je suppose que c'est
moins le cas que ça a pu l'être je pense
que les américains durant les dix années
qui ont suivi la guerre ont regardé un
peu partout sur la planète et se sont
dit qu'il leur fallait peut-être
s'impliquer plus que l'isolationnisme ne
les ai pas beaucoup
donc ils ont regardé comment les anglais
et les français avaient géré les choses
et se sont dit c'est pas terrible non
plus oui mais récemment on a eu le
retrait d'afghanistan
et si l'on en croit la presse ici je ne
sais pas à quel point ils sont proches
des services de renseignement le
gouvernement a été surpris par ce
retrait d'afghanistan
il pensait que cela n'arriverait pas est
ce que les américains retenait des
informations au cas où cela pourrait
fuiter depuis nos actuels services de
renseignement
ont ça pourrait bien être le cas il
pourrait bien avoir peur qu'il y ait des
fuites et des journalistes poserait des
questions à washington et embarrasserait
les américains
je peux tout à fait croire ça c'est un
accord de base de non-divulgation autres
espions et nos relations spéciales ont
toujours été plutôt tumultueuse
je pense qu'il est difficile de
généraliser
c'est une chose que je dirais je pense
que les relations personnelles sont très
importantes et dans certains cas elle
pourrait nuire à l'image d'ensemble
il est certain que dans le cas de
l'afghanistan
tout ce qu'on a pu voir suggère que les
britanniques ont tout à fait des prix de
court
des sports
j'espère que votre livre se vend bien
vous décrivez à quel point qu'en philby
essayé d'écrire des choses et de les
publier dans des journaux britanniques
les services de renseignement étaient
proches des propriétaires des journaux
leur disant vous ne touchez pas à ça
eleanor la dernière épouse et saïd de
publier quelque chose et les critiques
sont unanimes en mauvaise sans qu'aucun
élément de ce contexte complexe que ce
soit au niveau politique ou au niveau
psychologique
je ne sais pas si ce seront les
critiques faites à ce livre aussi la
volonté d'avancer et terrible arrêter de
penser aux complexités du cafi de
laïcité
oui c'est quelque chose que je disais à
quelqu'un l'autre jour ce samedi
en général la réaction des gens face à
adolf hitler n'est pas la colère c'est
la volonté de comprendre
un échec mais il me semble que philby a
aussi droit à une telle réaction
mais il ya beaucoup de gens en
angleterre qui voudraient frapper philby
je pense qu'il a fait de très mauvaise
chose mais quoi qu'il en soit quarante
ans après sa mort non 33 ans après sa
mort il a le droit à une sorte de
compréhension de ce stade je ne me vois
pas du tout comme étant son apologistes
je pense qu'il y as droit
james hanning merci
[Musique]